what's up everybody zeki here with geek
culture and in this video we are going
to take a look at one of the best budget
lighting kits you can get to take your
videos to the next level we are talking
about tick tocks insta stories live
streaming any video formats you can
think of now we've been using these
lights for a while now in our recent
videos and across different scenarios
and we gotta say they've been producing
some really impressive results so let's
talk pricing real quick pixel offers two
options you got the two pack and the
three pack coming in at 269.99
and the three pack coming at 379.99
us dollars you can find these guys in
the pixel store page on amazon and do
feel free to check out the links in our
description as well alright so let's
dive straight into the build quality and
design over here we have 552 led bulbs
inside this panel 156 cool leds 156 warm
leds and 204
rgb led bulbs yes it's got bi-color and
rgb so there's a lot of room to get
creative so like most leds in the market
it does come with band doors and it's
already mounted they are detachable but
we like to keep them on and this is how
we actually control the spill and
direction of light so the design on the
k80 video light is actually pretty
impressive we've got the u-shaped
bracket over here and this helps with
the 360 degree angle of rotation it's
going to provide you with more
maneuverability instead of just left and
right it's also going to swivel back and
forth right on top of that you do have a
diffusion
filter now you're not going to get those
sliding plates that comes in a more
premium lighting kit but this gets the
job done now as you can see it's just a
flimsy piece of plastic
and when it comes to mounting it it's
gonna take a little bit of fitness
and we like to keep the diffusion filter
on because one it helps soften the light
and two it helps protect the raw leds
from the elements now of course in more
premium kits you do have more of a
sliding plate system and that's what i
really wish we could see from the k80
but hey i do have to emphasize that this
is a budget lighting kit so you are
going to miss out on the quality and
some of the features of a more premium
package now it also comes with a very
nifty
soft carry-on case now the bag itself is
pretty basic but you are able to travel
with it the interior is all padded so it
keeps the panels protected as well in
fact we were really surprised that you
could store everything into this bag now
the light stand itself is not the best
it's not worth class and it's ideal for
situations where you'll be creating
videos at home or in the studio so
you're gonna experience some flex
between the segments and mounting the
panel on here is a little bit wonky as
well so i suggest getting a third-party
light stand
one cool thing i guess is the very long
legs when you unfold it and that gives
you a more wider surface area when it
comes to weight distribution
but because of that it's kind of like a
double edged sword here if anyone trips
on this light stand your panel is going
to go down as well nobody wants that so
if you're going to stick with these i
suggest getting sandbags
just to set them in place so again both
the panel and the light stand they are
lightweight but they are not as rigid
so i would really bear caution when it
comes to bringing these
outdoors especially the light stand
because
these can't take a beating at all but
with the panel itself it only weighs 1.4
kilograms or about 3.3 pounds so it's
very lightweight and you've got
portability there now speaking of
portability it also supports mpf
batteries you need two of these on each
panel and bing bam boom you are ready to
roll
so in terms of operability this is one
of the most easy to use panels you can
get that's also because it has an lcd
display panel at the back now this lcd
display gives you more finesse when it
comes to your adjustments
you can adjust from one percent
increments to 25 increments you can
adjust your light intensity your hue and
saturation and on top of that you can
also change modes so we're gonna dive
into the first mode which is cct or
correlated color temperature
and this is basically the bi-color mode
which adjusts from cool to warm and warm
starting at 260 000 kelvin to 10 000
kelvin that's really cool
of course we have to talk about the rgb
function or more eloquently called in
the industry hsi also known as hue
saturation and intensity now you're
gonna have a multitude of colors pixel
did not offer how many colors they are
but to simply put it's
all the colors in the rainbow
and when i say all the colors in the
rainbow i mean
this
of course if you're looking for a more
technical term for all my lighting
buddies out there then you want to look
at the cri rating also known as the
color rendering index and this has index
of 97.
that's almost very accurate not 100
but it's up there excellent excellent is
the word this means that the bouts
produce a more accurate color rendering
around the object and it's also going to
affect how accurate colors are going to
turn out in your video think of
situations where you would like more
accented lighting to really liven up the
mood or even more atmospheric lighting
to really set the tone and pace of your
film it only gets better because we have
one more mode to try which is scene mode
police
yes it simulates police lights ambulance
lights tv effects lightning effects and
even a disco party
yes and speaking of disco party we need
good quality sound so let's talk about
today's sponsor logitech
here at geek culture audio is a huge
part of our daily lives both work and
play so what's our choice of headphones
well meet the logitech g435 lightspeed
wireless gaming headset
it allows you to listen to all the rich
sounds from your music videos and games
across pc console and mobile while
spotting some popping vibrant colors not
only that it weighs just 165 grams which
means sometimes you even forget that
you're wearing it with the robust
battery life of 18 hours you can enjoy
your gaming sessions for prolonged
periods of time for more details head
over to logitechg.com
so yes the k80 rgb video light kit
a very good start for all you creators
gamers live streamers hobbyists and even
professionals this is an impressive kit
that covers the basics of lighting and
more for its price thanks for checking
out this video and if you're planning to
get the k80 video like kit for yourself
we do have the links in the description
below what do you think of the k80 what
do you think of the price does it stand
out to you let us know your thoughts
down in the comments below as well while
there give us a like and subscribe
thanks for watching the video again and
this is zeki signing off lights out